one out first inning anderson stands at
second anderson at second with one out
of the first inning no score one ball
two strike pitch to abreu and he hits
that one in the air into deep left field
gordon's just gonna admire this one as
it goes to the fountains in left two-run
homer jose abreu and the white sox jump
out to a two-nothing lead in kansas city
and he absolutely crushed it
location may have been wrong but still
the speed was a bad decision when
somebody's late on your fastball
now the o2 from geoleto and a swing of
the missed three straight change-ups
and strike three second strikeout for
giolito
in the air to left field and deep
jimenez is back and
bubba starling hits his first home run
of the year
but i'll tell you what that's a slider
that just stayed up and bubba he didn't
get it all but you don't need to you
leave a mistake up there like that
bubba's gonna get you and that is his
first bubba bomb of the year
here's ryan mcgroom
who was on
at the end of the third inning
and he's hitting for jorge solaire who
indeed is out with right oblique
soreness
and a 1-2 the count 2-1 the score white
sox in front the pitch
bouncing ball to the left side rolling
rolling in field of bare-handed by
franco throw across not going to be in
time but runs going to score
as mccann crosses home plate on that
ball that just hugged the line down the
third base side franco tried in vain to
throw out anderson but nothing doing
there it's now 3-1 white sox in the
fifth three balls two strikes two outs
there goes anderson the pitch high fly
ball deep left field this one's gone
way out of kauffman stadium
to the staircase just to the left of the
fountains
and yasmani grandahl
has made this a 5-1 white sox lead in
the fifth yeah baby
he did clear the left side it was the
same pitch that he had just fouled down
and now he crushes one out of here
[ __ ] coming up right here
michael franco hits one to the wall put
it he crushed that
here comes o'hard the third vance wilson
is going to wave him to the plate
anderson's relay is
a little bit late
[Applause]
sliding to the outside of all plate
and got the plate with his left hand and
michael franco picks up his 14th double
the year
scalded that baby has an 84 change up
right in the middle
hitters
vance wilson the third base coach sent
o'hern with a great slide
pondacy at the plate want to see bats
right-handed for the first time tonight
come on monday battling here
and he gets a base hit to left field so
battle he
does indeed and franco not only drives
in a run but now he scores a run and
we're back to a two-run game nice
well that just shows you
his impact
those ten stolen bases not only leads
the american league but
leads both leagues
there he goes and they haven't picked
off
throat goes down to second but it's high
and modesty off the bag now and is
tagged out by madrigal
didn't see a call yet
umpire saying that he pushed him off
call him safe he kept the tag on him
but uh madrigal saying he popped up off
of the base
and i don't know we saw that last night
and he actually kept his toe on the back
did not lose contact with it
and then the umpire is saying that he
continued to push him off the base not
his momentum carrying
you got to get an angle on this throw
and the biggest problem was he didn't
move to get the angle so the throw is up
now he does tag him
the question is
in the interpretation of the umpire does
that tag
mean he pushed him off
let's see
yeah he's out well done alex coleman
comes on to the 15th time era of 123.
behind him will be the best defensive
outfield the sox can put out there
with pitch number one that's hitting the
air
to right center field tracking that is
luis robert he dies and he's got it
an all-out dive into right center field
luis robert highway robbery
and it's the first time all year if you
ask me where you actually got to see
louise robert prove what he's capable of
doing when needed but cover from gap to
gap one ball one strike pitch to mod to
see here comes and a bouncing ball to
the right side tim anderson will field
and throw the first to the white sox win
it
white sox have beaten the royals again
tonight
and this one is a final score of five to
three